rassurer ses alliés c'est l'objectif de
joe biden le président américain entame
aujourd'hui une grande tournée en europe
premier déplacement à l'étranger depuis
sa prise de fonction l'amérique est de
retour c'est le message qui souhaite
délivrer après quatre ans de présidence
trump joe biden doit rencontrer demain
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson à la veille d'un sommet du g7
largement consacrée à la crise sanitaire
point final de ce voyage un sommet avec
nadine hier poutine le 16 juin à genève
un agenda chargé qui sera scruté de très
près par la russie notamment
sergueï lavrov le chef de la diplomatie
russe a tenu ce matin une conférence de
presse
on fait le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera gaufres et
la russie n'a pas d'ambition de
superpuissance a déclaré le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov la
russie est intéressée par des relations
pragmatiques mutuellement avantageuse
avec tout le monde que ce soit les états
unis ou l'union européenne ni les
sanctions ni les ultimatums ne
conviennent pour dialoguer avec la
russie je vous propose d'écouter nos
études nous sommes constamment
intéressés par des relations
pragmatiques mutuellement avantageuse
avec tous notamment l'occident lui même
que ce soit les états unis et leurs
alliés au sein de l'otan ou l'union
européenne il n'y aura pas de jeu à sens
unique ni les sanctions ni les
ultimatums ne conviennent pour dialoguer
avec nous nous n'avons pas d'ambition de
superpuissance même si certains se
convainc qu'il convainque tous les
autres du contraire nous n'avons pas non
plus l'ardeur messianique avec laquelle
nos collègues occidentaux s'efforce de
répondre leur ordre du jour en fondée
sur des valeurs démocratiques partout à
travers le globe
nous comprenons depuis longtemps que
l'imposition des modèles de
développement de l'extérieur n'aboutit à
rien de bon je tiens à souligner une
fois encore que nous nous prononçons
pour la coopération avec tous sur la
base du respect mutuel de l'égalité de
droit et de la recherche d'un équilibre
entre les intérêts
nous voyons la valeur individuelle dans
chaque partenaire international dans le
cadre des relations bilatérales
aussi bien que dans des domaines
internationaux je chéris sur l'amitié
avec tous ceux qui nous répondent par la
réciprocité et sont prêts à rechercher
des accords honnête au lieu d'essayer
d'utiliser des ultimatums et des
exigences unilatérale sergey lavrov a
également évoqué l'état des relations
russo américaines en vue du sommet
poutine byden qui se tiendra le 16 juin
à genève
le travail continue
il ne reste pas longtemps à attendre je
pense que bientôt tout sera clair nous
sommes intéressés à l'idée de résultats
positifs au sommet mais comme on dit il
faut être deux pour danser le tango
et si quelqu'un dans ce break dance ce
sera probablement plus difficile
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a également souligné que
malgré les divergences qui existent
entre les deux pays qui paraissent pour
certains insurmontable elle est
important de dialoguer au plus haut
niveau